yes next game rabitowski
USA 2400
had try this here a
different variant
still try to do a Benoni somehow so
here is ed5 a well known
variant that should actually be quite good
for
white
hm
a move that I initially see as strange
would see that
well, it's a strange rook position
that he
has now F4 games G4
threaten yes it looks
really terrible for Black at first
but maybe he can
really get enough counterplay here now that's
quite
possible
B5 h yes the R now somehow B4  and
knight E4
no, well maybe what he did wasn't so
stupid after all
t amazing and I think it
was completely pointless B4 Inter
he doesn't do knight E4 either he does something
else yes well okay of course he can
do that t yes that  I ca
n't believe in all of this, yes, with rook F5, but
actually black isn't that
bad, so I have no idea, but
at least it's standing, he's somehow got a
look at a game, if I can get
something swapped then
maybe it'll work out.
Bishop die2 was necessary too  Protect the C3 again
so yes, as I said, I definitely want to swap something here,
so maybe Rook
B3
then at the end Queen
B3 tur B1 Queen
A3 but wait a minute it actually threatens
something
somehow no actually not ne not
really even
make reinforcements H
very strange
position  Yes, now I could play this one,
I could kind of nose it, look for G4,
no where C3 could take it, I could really beat him,
but he actually has to be right. You have to do the math again, but the combination that makes bishop C3
looks like crazy. Yes, he has it
too  not done
so now it's standing there totally
knotted
sote
times like this maybe now
like this Queen B3 ma I
Rook B1 like Bishop
A3 Queen A3 Bishop
B1 Queen
A5 then Knight
E4 so now the rook can't move anymore
check but now that's actually a
rook  smooth
rook check check check check
check
well unfortunately at least one
permanent check
has reached
gunwale here I can't go to E4 because of
F5
check draw
offered check check check check check
check what a funny game